salut bébé, je parle aux poissons, toi
et moi, fils, nous sommes différents, nous sommes spéciaux,
nous sommes connectés à la terre et à la mer.
J'ai hâte de vous présenter toutes les
créatures majestueuses de notre planète et de
vous montrer à quel point elles sont géniales.  ce monde peut
être ouais toi et
moi je vais tuer
Aquaman même si je dois passer un accord
avec le diable pour le faire,
libère-moi de ma prison et tout mon
pouvoir sera à toi, la clé de cette
prison est  la lignée royale
elle-même, il a besoin de nous, nous sommes la fin de la
lignée non, nous
ne le sommes pas
ouais, Mana a pris
Junior,
il doit être
[Musique]
arrêté Je viens pour
tu détruis tout ce qu'il détient,
tu es
sanglant, viens chercher
lui Les billets pour Aquaman et le Royaume Perdu sont
en vente maintenant radio PG13 uniquement en salles le
22 décembre